the Joe Rogan experience I want to show
you these gloves I brought some gloves
to show you so these gloves right here
are what we're going to be doing for the
competition gloves the competition and
the training gloves the 7oz training
gloves and so pretty much what these are
so this one is the so is he developed a
different glove for MMA for competition
yeah yeah so this isn't UFC seen these
because they're yeah what to make some
adjustments yeah we're talking with the
UFC but these are yes so these are the
curved curved so it sets up that you're
in a curved position already on because
when you as you know when you get the
gloves now they're like a cardboard they
want to open your hand yeah there's
always one open hand this allows your
hand to stay in a natural fist locked
position and you don't got to worry
about that these are now getting on oh
yeah okay so it's curved right away yeah
and then when you that's way better
yeah like the old pride gloves yeah yeah
good padding too so it's I like them a
lot these are definitely better than the
ones UFC is using right now yeah so it's
you know if you see the X trapping
system in there that also goes in your
so in that way it makes it so that your
your your hand you don't get the boxing
break on your hand it keeps everything
all the muscles all the all the
ligaments and and bones in place so that
way when you punch and everything is is
in form so this is it says grappling
glove fires wrapping glove and fight
glove so these ones were the ones at the
factory and I had to hurry up and get
these out just talking I wanted to show
you these so this one is is this one is
is going to be like the training the
training one but we're gonna put a
different different head on the front of
it what's gonna be different about it
it's going to be just the
the top is gonna be different a little
bit more so you can punch with let you
can hit it with a sigh he decided to be
it'll be a little bit like this got some
sad panic yeah but it definitely better
than it'll be a side paddling like this
a little bit you know so it's gonna be a
bit bigger so wet that way right I can
hit like that and training like casting
punch as those right mm-hmm
I like these a lot I like these a lot
yeah I mean just I mean ah this but
Trevor's whole thing man you know it's
all about making it so that fighters can
do what they enjoy doing a lot longer
and be healthy about it you know and
he's Trevor's Trevor's a G when it comes
to adjusting and making what he needs to
for the fighter so they can so they can
continue to do what they want to do
he's a jut like he's made he's made head
gears for people too so because the one
one of these fighters had a broken nose
and he made a headgear and Haggar that
he made his guy it was it was sick how
does this work this is weird because
it's like both sides are male I see yeah
oh yeah so this this is go it goes
though the inside was on the inside oh
yeah it goes on the inside I gotta see
okay probably some weird go talk to
Trevor about the busy maybe it goes this
way first oh I bet that's exactly yeah I
bet it goes this way first yeah so you
can put yeah that's it that's the ground
I was like that you can pull this trap
on it yeah and then the strap goes over
okay I say and the strap goes over the
top these are great man well there's
definitely room for improvement the
current state of MMA gloves are the ones
that UFC uses they're they're better
than the original ones that they had a
few years back you know they improved
them maybe eight or nine years ago or
whatever it was but still those are
better well see I mean in US and that's
where we are at onyx you know we just
want to be able to get a product out
there for the athletes in it they can
they can use but it protects them
because a lot of a lot of the injuries
like 75% of them happen in training sure
you know and if we can kind of cut that
number down then they can have a lot
more of these fighters making these
dates you know and for the most part for
these fighters
you can actually you know for it you you
can have here that protects you and you
don't got to suffer these long injuries
like these ACLs right you know it helped
mitigate some of those things
[Applause]